shaq i have cara henderson snead on with
me as well because it's mimosa friday i
needed someone to drink with and someone
to tap dance because i knew you might be
late calling in but would you wear a
yellow fedora if we sent you one on the
set for tnt yeah
what's your fedora like a yellow like um
like a bowler hat like a really chic hat
if i send you a photograph of this hold
on i'm going to multitask because i'm a
mom and i could multitask i'm going to
send you a picture of kara wearing this
hat this is a live uh this is a live
i'm not sure what it is cara what is
this a live something or other shaq i'm
going to send you this hat i'm making
this happen it's a look
i want to see you wear this yellow hat
with like a yellow zoot suit i think
that would be a great look on tnt
he's trying to open it he's deciding i
don't have it yet
i might have to pass on my hat
[Laughter]
i saw the full length fur coat that you
wore to your plane the other day you
were wearing a fur hat and a fur coat
and you'd pass on this
well it's cold up here in cleveland
matter of fact it's freezing it's a
blizzard outside right now right now
excuse me yeah
there's snow everywhere my car is
blocked in i can't walk
i think they're going to cancel also
again there's so much you know out here
it can't be that is it really that much
nope
i just lied to you
[Laughter]
oh it's friday and if it's friday it's
the shaquille o'neal visit to me and
then 20 degrees
well it's too cold i mean i don't know
how you survive playing in boston you're
not a cold weather guy
no not at all i'm actually a tropical
big man but
i uh
so today i've got two events so i'm
about to wrap up right now and go to my
two events and just come back and watch
some netflix
what will you watch on netflix i want to
know what your viewing list is
right now i'm on the series from dusk to
about about vampires
that's good
and then i'm on uh power four
force
50 cent show power oh of course okay
yeah and then i'll watch any horror
movie that has a stupid title like
scream one two three four and seven did
you watch all of those
no i like i like
i like titles that are really good but
the movie's really bad titles like susie
schuster cuts your face at the beverly
hills hotel
you know what's funny i made a fortune
on that movie uh there's a sequel coming
up and saying susie schuster bumped you
in the back of your knees in the beverly
hills hotel you know i ran into shaq
last week which is why i booked him for
the show also everybody who watches this
show knows i don't do this show without
shaq he's like my security blanket but i
did sneak up behind him you know what he
did the knee thing where you just
pushed somebody's knees in and then i
thought what if i actually injured
shaquille o'neal accidentally that would
be a horror show
the crazy thing is after you did that my
my left hook reflexes almost turned
around but then when i saw it was he was
like abort abortion
[Music]
because that would have really sucked by
the way like go home with the black guy
mom what happened um shaq hit me in the
face can you imagine and that would not
be a that's a horror movie
i know shaq uh
you're in good shape now big guy what's
going on you look good
so i want to pose
topless on my birthday with the caption
that says does your daddy look like this
that's my dream to go on instagram one
last time so no this this you almost
i know but this is what it is i want to
i was trying to get the 12 pack i don't
have that much discipline i'm going to
go on and admit it to myself
but i don't want the otp
uh
b
that's the uh over the bell berkeley
belly
so i'm just trapped so
i'm i'm eating i'm going to diet well
not to keep my stomach flat like i'm 50
i don't need to not have practical 12
but i've had that but i'm just trying to
keep my stomach flat so
all right i eat healthy 70 of the time
and then i cheat in moderation so like i
was trying to do the 12 packet
veggie burger and veggie dish but i
can't take it i like my sandwiches like
my burgers are just gonna just gonna do
it in moderation but as long as my
stomach is flat i'm happy yeah you
facetimed me a couple times when you've
been cooking what's your cheat
i want to hear what what is on the menu
for a shaquille o'neal cheat day
uh two club sandwiches that's from
french fries
that's it i
was if i'm on the road
mcdonald's
mcdonald's and if i'm in and if i'm in
any of my cities with my restaurants big
chicken
but like i just i'm a sandwich guy i
just love sandwiches
all right next time you're in town i'll
i'll get out the the old press hey um
by the way and i'll order you something
because who am i
i've never seen you make out
yeah a panini i have a panini press it's
in a box
yeah a panini you know with a with a
bread that's toasted and delicious no
rich people always trying to
i'm sorry that's not rich jack has no
money i didn't drive away in a bentley
or a rolls royce
now you're telling all my secrets
and the license plate there goes the
everyman status
uh
how was watching the super bowl for you
we uh we faced time during it i got
straight i got street cred for my kid i
said look who it is and and they're like
okay and that was it that's all i got i
got nothing how was it for you watching
another team like this win big in la
it was fun i was but
it was different you know because after
the game i thought the series was going
to be a little bit more on fire
you know
i mean it was it was you know people
were stuck people were celebratory but
you know i couldn't remember when we was
you know tearing up some stuff and a
couple fires and a couple turned over
police cars that i had to pay for but
i'm happy for the rams i'm happy for the
city
um i just hate that
when you win a championship people have
to question it i know they got three
calls in a row
i know that but you know i would like to
just
blow the other team up but i'm happy
because i have it i have a guy on both
sides so whoever would have won i
definitely would have been happy
who are your guys on both side check
joe burroughs lsu odell beckham jr lsu
so it's all about school for you
all about schools for me because i even
know i was at the super bowl cheering
i'm a cowboy fan do not get interested
i'm always getting cowboys and i will
always be a couple of five through the
good the bad and the ugly
and it's ugly but you know and also you
know the tj's in the corner right now
and he's kind of happy about that
because tj you have a question for shaq
and there's something burning in your
brain well it wasn't even the question
for shaq it was just like you know shaq
i've got a velvet rope up in front of my
desk here and it's because you get to
the point
the point shack is a lot of a lot of
people like to talk trash about the
cowboy shack so i like i devised the
system determining if their team that
they root for it was good enough for me
to argue with them about football based
on whether or not they wanted to talk
trash on the cowboys so that's that's
basically
what that one mentioned this
i was on my podcast the other day i
mentioned this about the cowboys i
wanted somebody to go with it but this
is what i think
if you look at the job that deon sanders
is doing at jackson state
that's the type of
that's the type of energy we needed
cowboys i don't know who the new culture
of the cowboy is but i think you should
bring dion back home he played there he
knows the system he knows what it takes
to play
i think he can definitely get the guys
ready so dion sanders should be the next
cowboys coach
i love that's a great time well and you
know jerry shack like he he he goes back
and forth like a a coach that's a little
bit more he can control and then he goes
the other direction and gets a coach
that's gonna do his own thing so that
would certainly be going back in that
other direction for sure and he loves a
big name and he loves a big splash and
and boy dion's done a great job yep
and not only that dion would hold these
guys accountable
i think this is a genius idea there you
know and it won't be on their phones in
the locker room have you seen that video
he's like get off your phones or you're
not playing i'm like i love that
i love it i saw that [ __ ] you know all
one thing
like
when phil came and you know susie knows
this because she was there
he held me accountable
like hey man you listen to me free
throws off amen you
you know
put on some problems
hey man you're not doing this hey man
stop fighting yeah like like she held me
responsible
and that's what some of these superstars
need these days well they want it don't
they shack don't they want that like to
a certain degree at least within the
bounds of the playing field it seems
like from watching the jordan
documentary that's what feels so good at
doing
like holding you accountable for your
your basketball play but then letting
you be
who you are outside of the outside of
the building sean's like that
yeah so
but
you know from somebody's dad the younger
generation they just want to
you just pay him and then you just move
out the way you allow them to have
excuses and this and that i don't know
if
it's different
kids these days shaquille o'neal here on
the rich eisen show susie schuster cara
henderson stayed with me as well you
bring me to the ben simmons question
because i think you're talking about
these young players right now and we've
been talking about it the last couple
days marshall faulk and i were talking
about it yesterday about
mental health mental illness but also
just needing to look into yourself to
want to be better
to not have to have a coach tell you
and push you but reacting that way
what's your what's your thought check
i would like to talk to a mental health
expert
i want to know can mental fortitude
be looped inside of mental health and
mental illness because i don't know
i just know that
you have to have tough mental fortitude
to be great you have to have
excellent mental fortitude to be one of
the greatest
criticizing comes with the game
i said on tv you don't think would they
ask phil jackson could you win with
missing free throws
he probably said the same thing doc said
you don't think i've looked in the
stands and seeing you and rich make a
face with down by one when i mess with
free throw you don't think i you know
you should when i'm walking around and
people saying hey he's a great player
but he can't make a freak up
you don't think that bothered me
but i had the tough mental fortitude to
get through it and persevere
because i wanted to be great when i
first when i first got to l.a jerry west
sat me down and said
at the end of this thing whenever you
retire you could either be up there with
the greats or it's going to be a bus and
it'll be the one the biggest bus in
history i don't want to be a bus i don't
want to be on that side of history i
want to be on it i did whatever i had to
do i sucked it up i let people talk
susie was there i wanted to beat
teammates up and as soon as he would
calm me down and suzie was like you know
what if i give her a wrong answer she's
like i'm not going to print at you kill
that's going to cause problems that's
why i love susie because
she was honest she had integrity but she
also taught me because i would just say
whatever she'd like to kill am i going
to say that
maybe you should say it like this she's
actually like a teacher
so that's why whenever susie calls i
consider her rich friends but
i need to find out
is there a difference can they
intertwine with each other because i
don't know
i don't want to say the wrong thing i do
know that when i run around la
and i see those people
living on the streets
to me
that's mental illness i wanted to do a
show one time about you know i just
wanted to hang out with a homeless
person and you know
just hang out with them see what they're
going through and try to help them get a
job
no company would insure it because they
said mentally they don't know what a
person could do or would do
don't come to me with insurance like i
just want to stay out there 30 days with
them don't bother me
no no leaving food on the side i was
just going to actually see what it feels
like for 30 days but
i know that those people have mental
problems and
it's just hard for me to believe that a
guy that's making 40 50 million
all of a sudden it just comes and then i
also want to know can they just come all
of a sudden
because like if you're 17 and you tell
me that you've had it and like you're 30
we already know but can you just come
come out of nowhere and say i got it i
mean i i need to know these questions
because i don't want to say the wrong
thing and disrespect
people you know what i mean so
i need to reach out to dr oz with dr
j and ask these questions because i
don't really know
two more questions for shaquille o'neal
he's joining us on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line so jerry west was with
us yesterday and really went deep into
his own experience
with mental health and the dark days
that he had when he played and even
went so far as to say yesterday was a
bad day or the day before was a bad day
and really shared with us it really
touched a lot of our viewers and
listeners
did you ever have those kind of days
have you had those kind of days shaq
oh all the time
but i don't you know i don't i don't
wanna
i don't know what it is i just know that
when you're
raised by a drill sergeant you're
trained a certain way
i'm not allowed to have those days i'm
not allowed to feel down
because you know what about the people
that are really gone through stuff
you don't know me like
i understand those people but i've i've
always had
coping mechanisms on how i get out i
don't know what what it's called but
i don't want to say it's that because i
don't know if it's that but i never
like you know my motto is to just be
happy
take care of the people and just stay on
on a righteous positive path
but everyone has dark days but i just
always try to you know bounce back
so what's your message then to ben
simmons as he now joins a new team seems
to come back in with a smile on his face
and joins the new jersey nets what's
your message
i do not have a message for him
i wish him well
uh hopefully all his dreams come true
i hope he uh
wins a championship i hope he finds
ways to co
to to cope with what's
going to continue to happen criticism
will never stop social media will never
stop
you miss a shot down by one the faces
will never stop so
hopefully design ways to cope with that
because guess what magic went through it
bird went through it
oh forget the names that you're there
what about bill russell couldn't stay in
the in the white hotels and you know
could only have to drink out the color
only faucets and he would ride and he'd
be separate from his team he'd get death
threats
you you don't think you have stuff to
you know go through and
you know stop the battle so i i don't
have the message out you know well i
wish everybody will
shaq i wish you well don't get too cold
i know you brought yourself a a bear to
wear
excuse me you know why i'll never be
cold
oh god i'm scared why
because i looked in the mirror and i was
like damn i'm hot
diesel
have a good time
chef that shaquille o'neal everybody
yes it is that's shaquille o'neal the
one
the only shaquille o'neal hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here